mareo pensó que visitar a su mamá era
seguro
su mamá ahora saben que no lo fue el
kobe no mata solo no seamos cómplices
esta es la campaña del gobierno peruano
que busca un comportamiento responsable
de sus ciudadanos ante la pandemia de el
coronavirus que es fundamental que son
duros pero es necesario para que
reflexione las personas que se resiste a
cumplir y también lo de su entorno para
que los hagan tomar conciencia pero la
estrategia residuos duras críticas en
redes sociales y contrario a los
esperados por las autoridades indignó a
muchos y polarizó a los peruanos el
gobierno ha asumido que metiéndole temor
a las personas acá tengo un poco más las
leyes pero también tiene la contra que
generando problema puede aumentar puede
generar más obra de la que ya estamos
viviendo es tuvieron que tomar un poco
más de tiempo para agarrar una
información concreta y así informar más
a la población que darle miedo tú le has
miedo a una persona y la persona se
angustia y hace cualquier cosa puedo
sobrevivir o no totalmente la tiene la
culpa el gobierno
aquí quien tiene la culpa es el pueblo
peruano que no tiene la conciencia ni la
responsabilidad de cuidarse cada uno
para el analista en comunicación
política luis benavente la campaña
estigmatiza una parte de la población
encierra un concepto equivocado
básicamente culpando a un segmento de
peruanos de clase media baja clase media
clase media baja como los responsables
de las infecciones lo cual es
estigmatizar a ese sector de peruanos
mestizos tal como lo representa la
campaña como que si la clase alta y los
blancos de clase alta no fueran también
irresponsables los peruanos se esperan
que la vacuna contra el coach 19 no
demore mucho y si todo sale bien tendrán
que seguir luchando para recuperarse de
la recesión que vive el país